he is Brian when horse from the
worldwide leader in sports how are you
Brian hey rich where are you where have
I caught you
luckily I am home this week after four
straight weeks on the road
Oh buried in snow but okay yeah no look
man it's uh it's it's in the NBA world
you're on the jump you're all over the
place you're going everywhere so I
appreciate it sounds like you're
recovering from from the travel so I
appreciate you you calling it LeBron and
the Lakers after losing on Saturday
night in New Orleans he was asked after
the game about some of his teammates and
he said sometimes you gotta understand
that it's you know being uncomfortable
or that it's something that that happens
and a lot of these guys haven't been
made to feel uncomfortable how
uncomfortable is it in team LeBrons camp
best you can tell right now right which
I'm really trying to figure out what
sort of code he's talking again you know
he does this he's joked in the past
about how he talks in code because I'm
trying to read it because to me what I
kind of think he's saying is if you want
me to give maximum effort and you want
me to go all-out which is what the
Lakers needs I got to see all these
other guys going all-out and I think
that's what he's saying and I'm being
clear I'm trying to pull my way through
the weeds here and he's saying that you
know that maybe they're not a hundred
percent focused on this but he says that
in the same week that they announced
when spacejam is coming out now I'm not
saying that he's not a hundred percent
devoted but it it it's kind of a mixed
message to his teammates and at the end
of the day I actually don't think it's
it's that complicated LeBron makes it
complicated with some of his comments
but the Lakers are an average team rich
they were an average team in July when
they put this group together and their
situation has been compounded by
injuries so they're an average team
that's been injured and what you have is
a team it's in 10th place at the end of
the day to overcome being there
averageness they either need LeBron to
play great which has happened sometimes
but not all the
time or they need to go over their heads
and shoot the ball really well which
they don't normally do or play really
good defense which they don't normally
do so they have moment we've now seen 60
games they're an average to below
average teams well I mean obviously the
Bron would have known that when he
signed on the dotted line to Brian so
the question is with him saying hey I'm
giving the team 3 plus 1 and that was so
much was made of that because he didn't
give the Cavaliers a 3 plus 1
opportunity with him in the last couple
of years Brian so the question is is
knowing that where does the next step
plan sit right now is we're getting set
to turn into march with what we saw that
went down with Anthony Davis trade
deadline time well they signed him at
about 6 o'clock Pacific Coast time on
July 1st just about every move that they
made after that in my opinion was wrong
I kind of understood the Rondo signing
because I understood that it was going
to give LeBron sort of another guy to be
a leader and a to share the load a
little bit but I kind of get that but
everything else they did I didn't
understand and so I don't know if LeBron
was completely apprised of all of those
plans but just just think of the concept
that they signed Michael Beasley instead
of Brook Lopez think about how much
different it would be for this team if
they had Brook Lopez who is one of the
best shooters shooting big men in the
league on this team right now my gosh he
might be worth three or four games to
them they might be in the eighth seed
going for six or seven right now I just
think that you know we say that he knew
what he was getting into I just can't
believe that that he knew that the team
was going to be this this was going to
be the roster when they when they got to
training camp so I think what he
basically did receive vote he put a vote
of confidence in to the Lakers franchise
in the city of Los Angeles he's
basically saying just like I really
wanted to play in Los Angeles for the
premier franchise
other people will want to come and he's
not wrong Anthony Davis wants to be
there right now they didn't work out how
he's gonna happen but I think that's
ultimately his wager is at the drawing
power of the purple and gold and that
city will ultimately work out however
it's going to go and right now looks a
little shaky but in a year he could end
up having really been smart
Brian Winn Horst here on the Rich Eisen
show I'll ask you the same question I
asked daryl morey when he was sitting to
my right in this chair on Thursday
morning here in Los Angeles prior to
that game against the Lakers do you
think and he said he didn't think so do
you think players who are free agents to
be have already made their decisions or
signaled their decisions to teams
lending actual credence to media
conversations about conversations
between Kyrie and Durant or what the
Knicks did with the porzingis trade
knowing somebody had already signaled
their coming do you think that's already
happened again as we're sitting here
late February I think there's been some
eyelashes batted but what I'll say about
these guys is they're prone to changing
their mind I mean let's just take Kyrie
Irving as an example there's a guy who
not only went out and said that he was
resigning back in October but he made a
commercial in the Boston Garden
where he said I hope to have my number
in the Raptors in the rafters for Nike
that commercial has run hundreds of
times in front of millions of eyeballs
and then he comes back and says asked me
again on July 1st which by the way is
probably the best way to put it asked on
July 1st look at the very moods that
Kevin Durant has been in this year if he
was a free agent 15 minutes after
draymond Green ripped him a new one and
got suspended in LA back to whatever was
in november/december what would he have
signed ask him again 15 minutes after
they might win their third straight
championship I think as a team you're
hedging and you're leaning and you're
trying to read the tea leaves but I
think it's preposterous to think that
these
have their minds made up so this is what
I always say about free agency making
assumption that I stayed this whether
it's February or November I'll say it
again if you would ask me in April
making assumptions about free agency
before we get to the really the end of
June before we get to the draft is is
foolish you're only making yourself out
to be mocked later now you could take an
educated guess and be right but I think
these teams are lining up for the
potential of it happening I don't think
anything's locked down and if you think
it's locked down you're really taking a
gamble it is not smart what about the
idea that anybody signs with clutch
sports in rich Paul is preparing to try
and play for LeBron in the next two or
three years with his waning window as
draymond Green just signed with them
Brian is that a fair assessment well I
think at the end of the day here's what
you have to realize about rich Paul his
career with LeBron in representing
LeBron is kind of over he's done his
last contract for LeBron James LeBron
gets into the contract it may be for a
year somewhere his business going
forward is to service his clients well
and so that he can draw other clients if
Anthony Davis says to him I want to go
play for the Lakers his job is to try to
get him to the Lakers but he can't
survive as an agent for the next 30
years which is what he wants to do by
only servicing one client LeBron James
and I agree that it's a sexy storyline
that he is only operating for LeBron but
he can't do something for draymond they
would only benefit LeBron he can't do
something for Anthony Davis they would
only benefit LeBron otherwise he's going
to lose all of his clients so yeah I
just don't think it's rational I know
that the conclusions that are going to
be jumped to and obviously LeBron is his
most important client his first client
and all that stuff it's just not the way
that they have done business is I've
looked at you know they've done
contracts with a lot of different teams
he's got a he's got 17 or 18 clients
right now this is not a small operation
no III
I totally hear you Brian when Horst of
ESPN joining here and and I I agree with
you mostly but I will say this and you
know this is well having been around
LeBron and maverick Carter and everyone
that has been put together by LeBron for
his business and they are savvy people
they are smart people they know exactly
what they are doing best of their
ability if I was LeBron and I would make
sure that every aspect of my world was
geared towards not only making my
present successful but setting up the
next next situation
you mentioned Space Jam being announced
this week I don't think that that is an
indication of LeBron not being focused
on trying to make the playoffs that's an
indication of why LeBrons here in Los
Angeles okay
and knowing that rich Paul and clutch
Sports has its own business and they do
have to grow it so it is successful long
after LeBron is done playing I wouldn't
if I'm a Bron I'm using that best of my
ability to get guys in right now to help
me win because that helps make more
space James do you see what I'm saying
that makes sense here but here's the
thing you have to take each individually
draymond Green is I don't want to use
this analogy so I wish I could use a
better one draymond Green is preparing
for war this summer rich this summer he
is eligible for contract extension he
believes whether he's right or wrong
that he has been underpaid the last few
years and that his underpaying and his
recruiting helped them get Durant you
look at him though in his last two
seasons he has been in decline
two years ago he was up to the top of
his game the last two years he was in
decline we have the potential for an
all-out fight between the Warriors and
draymond this summer over a contract
extension that could go so sideways that
he could end up demanding a trade or the
Warriors knowing how nastiness is
potentially going to get could trade him
in advance of it especially if Durant
walks it is time for him right now to
prepare to go to battle and rich Paul
has shown that he will go to battle not
with LeBron does
but if you go back and look at the way
he went to battle with Eric Bledsoe
where they dragged that fight all the
way out until mid-september to get a
contract with who the Cavs the Lakers
know the Phoenix Suns he was in holdout
situations with Tristan Thompson and
junior Smith to drag into the season yes
those are with the Cavs but rich Paul
has expressed the desire to willing to
go to war he went to war with Anthony
Davis you know in this trade demand that
is what draymond Green is hiring he is
hiring a wartime consigliere because he
knows that coming up this summer is
about to be the Battle of his career
from a contractual standpoint that's why
he hired him
is there an ancillary situation where
there's a trend the Lakers out there
yeah I guess but I don't I just don't
believe that draymond was on here
speaking candidly that he would tell you
that his desire to match up to be with
LeBron in LA is a reason the reason is
because he knows that this guy is not
afraid to go out there and take fire for
him just like you did white Ryan one
horse few minutes left here or the Rich
Eisen show and part of the reason why in
my mind all of this stuff is paramount
to have a conversation about on February
25th is we are waiting for something to
happen to beat the Warriors it could it
be free agency and certainly if teams go
in and try and take Durant or somebody
from where the end breaks it up because
as you just mentioned wants to go to war
to try and get his and draymond Green
which is entirely his prerogative no
question or somebody might actually beat
them on the floor
the Rockets win there this weekend what
do you take out of that Ryan well one
thing I would say is I was at that game
in LA last week that the Lakers won I
thought Chris Paul looked fantastic I
know that everybody was focused on me on
the refereeing and everything and that's
fine
watching Chris Paul move around that
court it was the best he's looked all
year and so to me if you're looking for
a reason that the Rockets have a chance
it's Chris Paul's health and he looked
and I know
they've only been about 500 since he
came back but I was incredibly
encouraged by the way he moved on that
court and he went up to Golden State and
had another terrific game even without
Harden I would say that at the end of
the day is anybody in this league
beating the Warriors 4 out of 7 if
they've got the majority of their team I
just don't see it definitely possible I
mean last year it almost happened they
were down 3-2 it could have happened
beating those guys four out of seven
with their margin for error and their
firepower and their experience I just
don't I just don't see it I'm I would
love to watch somebody get close to try
but I think that the league in all
honesty Durant
leaving the Warriors no matter where he
went I think would be good for the
league
it would make the league more
competitive and I think that you know
the league office may never say it but I
don't think they would mind it and I
think that's really what the most
important factor for the whole NBA is
the balance of power is what Kevin
Durant decides to do and that's why you
know Kevin can complain about it and he
can he can say that it's not fair and
that it's not real life for my Kyrie
says but there's a real reason why he
was paying attention there's tens of
millions of fans and billions of dollars
at stake and a lot of the power will go
where he goes that's why I believe that
Kevin Durant is the most powerful man in
the NBA right now he's more powerful
than any owner he's more powerful than
any player than any team what he decides
to do has the most power not necessarily
because it's all about him but because
him leaving the Warriors would change
things so much he's the unrestricted
free agent so it's gonna be a
fascinating time I wish I could say that
the finals would be the apex of the NBA
season that's the way it really should
be the apex of the NBA season will be
between July 1st and July 4th with all
these guys figure out where they're
going Brian always loved our chats you
really have a way of putting it in a way
of taking your knowledge and funneling
it and
in a very comprehensive and compelling
way I really appreciate you calling in
thanks rich have a good week right back
at your YouTube the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience